a warning this morning about the dangers
of using counterfeit makeup and other
knock knock off products like two-faced
and Cologne
US Customs and Border Protection seized
a record number of counterfeit goods
last year worth nearly 1.4 billion
dollars now one of their top priorities
is spotting these fake toiletries that
can be hazardous to your health
Jamie yuccas is in a warehouse near the
Long Beach Seaport where officers are
taking a closer look at some suspicious
packages Jamie good morning good morning
most of these boxes still awaiting
inspection are from China and Hong Kong
customs officers say last year alone
they seized more than two-thousand
shipments of counterfeit beauty products
in fact a fake personal items are now
more common than knockoff handbags these
customs officers are the first line of
defense for catching illegal shipments
and while the products here may be fake
they can have very real health
consequences for consumers beauty
blogger Tanya Arguello found that out
firsthand when she purchased a popular
eyeshadow from this downtown Los Angeles
Street market last year u.s. customs
officers say most of the discounted
goods sold here likely snuck in under
the radar at seaports like Long Beach I
just wanted to know can this possibly be
as good as the $50 that I just spent she
tested both eyeshadows and when she woke
up the next morning the doctor just to
get this taken care of so it doesn't get
worse within the first 45 minutes I
realized that it was an eye infection I
couldn't get my contacts on I look back
at the footage and it was on the fake
side on the side that I'd use the fake
product 100% Arguello isn't alone other
people who've used counterfeit makeup
have reported allergic reactions we
wanted to find out how easy it is to
find these products so we went shopping
undercover at the same downtown alley
most of the fake makeup sold here is
half the price of the original
vendors admitted the products were
knock-offs but assured us they were just
as good what is the same thing as
everything back at a gray Asus studio we
compared our purchases with the same
makeup from traditional retail stores
the packaging is nearly identical that's
interesting the colors show up pretty
different some fake makeup made in
factories like these has reportedly been
found to contain dangerous chemicals
such as arsenic mercury and aluminum we
sent the fake and real versions of this
MAC lipstick and this jaclyn hill i
shadow palette to a lab where they were
tested for 12 different metals most
concerning some of these eyeshadows in
the fake palette had nearly four times
the amount of lead as those in the real
version in one the amount exceeded the
fda recommended maximum of ten parts per
million
the fake lipstick had nearly 15 times
the amount of lead as the real thing
often the unsafe consumer goods are made
in factories that have unsanitary
conditions so the quality is not what
you needed to be Customs and Border
Protection says these counterfeit
products are costing the cosmetics
industry about seventy five million
dollars a year they see reducing the
amount of fake products smuggled into
the country could be as simple as
educating customers the furthest they
think is I'm just buying a fake pallet
they don't think that they could be
ingredients in here that could put my
heart at risk
fake makeup is not just sold in downtown
Los Angeles customers also need to
really be aware online if the price
seems too good to be true it probably is
beauty bloggers say to make sure you're
getting the real deal go to the cosmetic
company's website and see where they
officially sell their product viana
great tips and great investigative work
as well Jamie thank you fortunately our
makeup teams here only buy authentic
products right yes everybody like the
deals right after the break too good to
be true as probably
great